bonjour guillaume delpy merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nos
stickers bonjour merci d'être avec nous
ce matin en direct sur arte france alors
le chef de l'état a dit que les
enseignants devaient se faire vacciner
ce sera le cas probablement d'ici à la
mi-avril fin avril qu'en pensez vous en
tant que parents d'élèves le virus
circule beaucoup à l'école vous le
constatez alors oui effectivement c'est
vrai que le virus circule beaucoup
actuellement à l'école et la non de
l'échelle de l'état ne peut être que
d'une façon positive par par des parents
d'élèves
après comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure voilà c'est une annonce je ne
sais pas comment cela va se mettre en
place
est ce que les enseignants vont pouvoir
se vacciner mais effectivement je pense
que c'est une bonne mesure si les
enseignants à se faire vacciner
rapidement puisqu'ils sont assez exposé
effectivement dans les écoles alors vous
nous disiez 1 que le ciri le virus
circule est activement dans l'est dans
les écoles en tout cas celle que vous
fréquentez qu'est-ce qui est mis en
place aujourd'hui très concrètement est
ce que les élèves peuvent se faire
tester par exemple alors il n'y a pas de
à ma connaissance il n'y a pas de tests
qui sont organisées pour les élèves dans
les écoles
après ce qui est mis en place enfin mois
par rapport à ce que je connais bien par
rapport à mes enfants
voilà ce sont des règles sanitaires très
strictes le port du masque de la
distanciation
voilà une vigilance accrue de la part du
personnel enseignants et du personnel
éducatif et je crois que bel effet que
ce soit les chefs d'établissements des
proviseurs ont des enseignants voilà
sont extrêmement vigilants
il faut que les parents aussi passent de
bons messages à leurs enfants et je
pense qu'avec ça alors ça ça se passe
bien dans leur établissement scolaire
il faut il faut vraiment sensibiliser
des enfants pour au match
les règles qui sont demandées par les
établissements scolaires c'est un fait
30% de circulation du virus en plus dans
les écoles que la moyenne nationale
jean-michel bancaire le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a dit que le
risque en valait la peine c'est-à-dire
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes au
risque d'être contaminé même dans les
foyers est ce que c'est une crainte de
la part des parents alors oui ça fait
toujours une crainte de la part des
parents que j'ai effectivement le le
virus puisse passer par par leurs
enfants
mais je peux vous dire que en tant que
parent d'élève on est content que nos
enfants puissent continuer à aller à
l'école commenterait pas la position de
jean-louis c'est le banquet rue mais
mais en tant que parents voilà on
souhaite que nos enfants puissent
continuer à aller à l'école
c'était extrêmement difficile pour un
certain nombre de parents des filles
pour le premier confinement tels qu'ils
ont vécu en mars avril deux victoires
voilà il ya eu des situations
extrêmement tendue au sein des familles
dont les parents d'élèves oui ils sont
heureux que leurs enfants puissent
continuer à les allées à l'école et je
pense que pour un certain nombre
d'enfants aussi c'était c'était
absolument nécessaire c'est à dire que
l'hypothèse d'une éventuelle fermeture
d'école si les hausses de contamination
si les contaminations continuer leur
rose finalement la question elle ne se
pose pas encore pour vous en tant que
parent d'élève non non non la question
se pose pas pour le moment mais les
parents d'élèves l'accepterons si si si
c'est vraiment la solution qui devait
être mise en place
je pense que des parents d'élèves va on
accepter avec difficulté après tout sera
fait pour que ça se passe
mieux vaut mieux entre les parents et
des établissements et des enseignants
voilà il faut dans des cas difficiles
comme ça il très important que
l'ensemble des membres de la communauté
éducative que deux sont des parents les
enseignants le personnel à la direction
d'école
voilà travaillent ensemble et trouvent
les meilleures solutions pour que ça se
passe au mieux pour les enfants parce
qu'il faut pas oublier alors on parle
des parents par des enseignants mais il
faut pas oublier que l'école c'est
d'abord les enfants
merci beaucoup guillaume dépit d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france